guys that used to play rugby with I  imagine you're competitive you would  talk maybe you would kind of like scrap  at them a little bit every once in a  while things get heated we used to like  a back when we were playing football  like you would always uh yeah again Mad  Mondays everything would happen like  they've been going for a couple of days  and then they're just running at each  other remember no that's just in the  undies actually yeah because we call it  no undi Mundy  undies you've got to wear shorts and if  you're wearing undies they just rip them  straight off so we call them no Andy  Mundy yeah you can imagine the boys are  doing proper head UPS you know what I  mean you know lining up you know shirts  off and wearing footy shorts with no  undies so you know the Junk's moving  around yeah so they're just they're  running straight at each other bang and  you're just saying heads arms and balls  just flying in here